tell I have an idea there are bad people
out there come on Lisa it'll feel
good that hand was going to do terrible
things first question for both of you I
want to tease your relationship in the
movie A little bit so Katherine can you
tell me something that Lisa sees in the
creature that draws her to him and then
Cole the opposite for you something he
sees in her that Sparks that love well
we first meet creature in a cemetery and
he's not alive yet so I think the thing
that attracts Lisa to him is that he
doesn't
talk she can just look at his pretty
face and say whatever she needs and she
never feels judged Now isn't that sweet
it's so relatable too we all fall in
love with the picture right this is why
people love dogs more than other human
beings I know they don't talk back so I
think it's that then again sometimes
they do sometimes mine does mine speaks
you're three portals yeah um I think
well I think Lisa brought him back to
life and gave him a second chance so I I
I think there's I think there's a lot to
be in love with it's sort of like this
Angelic being to creature he's
immediately obsessed and very thankful
understandable understandable all right
so I was reading a quote Zelda Gabe
where she emphasized that she really
wanted to get like really colorful and
over the top with this movie so I'm
going to make you answer for each other
again can you each give me an example of
a time when the other was to totally
Fearless with their performance took
something to an 11 and just like really
blew your mind with how far they went
with it you know I don't actually think
it's in the Final Cut of the movie but
there is a scene where we're laying in
bed not to spoil too much but we're
laying in bed and we're drinking milk
and which is already awesome um as one
does uh some post qual milk um but the
original the original scene of the movie
was us uh smoking weed and and the
vapors are coming through the holes in
my chest oh that's clever and
um you gave a very different version of
the scene uh than what ended up in the
the scene that we have is a little bit
lighter in tone but you gave a really
really
introspective and uh like a longing kind
of take and I really I really liked that
take we had to because of uh the
limitation for the smoke and and all
that sort of stuff it didn't end up in
the Final Cut but I really liked that
take so the one that's in is just
terrible I mean you're good in every
scene but that one surprised me because
I didn't read the the scene like that
initially yeah wow um I do love that
scene I wish it stayed in I like the
version that we had though that scene
was very difficult to get through the
scene right before it I just couldn't
stop laughing we had a lot of days where
we couldn't stop laughing but for me the
scene that stands out with Cole's
performance is the very first scene we
shot with you where you come in with the
axe oh yeah the big scene yeah I think
it was just um you know so much of this
movie relies on Cole and his bringing of
this character to life this Larger than
Life character and he came in with this
physicality and it was so Corky and like
lovable and he does so many evil things
in the movie and after that day it felt
like we had a movie I felt like oh yeah
I think it was the first scene that I
did yeah such a good example of a
perfect physical performance and also
the way they capture that particular
shot like the angle just really enhances
what you doing yeah Zelda you know Zelda
was really smart about it too um because
she in the very beginning I had talked
to her about I was working with a
movement coach and I said you know hey a
lot of a lot of the emotion of this
character relies on his physicality
being seen and she was like you know
from the beginning I've always imagined
most of your shots are wide shots so
that we can capture a lot of you uh
which really helped cuz meant that I
could be more exaggerated and I can
actually have that that sort of space to
play so she she was very understanding
of that and yeah it was just it was
really reassuring oh I have to ask you
about working with Lauren on the the
movement coach stuff can you tell me
maybe one specific thing he taught you
that wound up being a pillar to the
performance and we can see in the Finish
absolutely you know when you think of
like miming you you you think of the
invisible rope or you think of like the
box but he um he was a student of Marcel
Maro marel had a teaching called the
attitudes which I really liked and the
attitudes were an attempt to discover a
kind of universal language for how we
understand emotion physically and uh the
example he used was we pretended like I
was a statue for anger as an example
what would that statue look like yeah do
you hold yourself up what are your arms
doing what are your feet doing and we
went through tons of different emotions
and then we we would compare to maro's
version of that emotion cuz your body
holds emotion and the most surprising
part about it was how similar we
instinctually go to these certain
gestures um and there there actually is
a kind of language in those gestures and
I I found that just fascinating it was
so much fun for some reason I feel like
I sat up a little straighter exactly
right like how you carry yourself
outward if it's an inward thing where
you put your arms and your legs it was
fun fascinated by his work I was just
talking to the team behind SAS Watch
Sunset and I'm like my God like this
person needs to be in the spotlight more
for how he contributes someone
performance he's so cool something else
so Katherine for you I have a question
about Carla because I'm always here to
Sing Carla Gino's Praises incredible
seriously I think one of the best of the
best yet another person in this industry
that just consistently needs more credit
than she gets abut what is something you
saw her do on this set that wowed you
maybe even something you back pocketed
and would like to try on a future film
yourself I felt like she was so um so
free yet always knew how to keep it real
and on a set like this with Limitless
opportunity and places to go in the
script she never overacted she always
kept it cool and I think I watched her
hold back and in doing that it created a
really interesting thought-provoking
performance and you know she took a lot
of hits there from this actually
genuinely she genuinely took a lot of
hits I I was going to say she there's
that scene where we you
know something bad happen something bad
happens to her and I hit her with a prop
typ writer um and in the first take I
totally misjudged it and smacked her in
the back of the room it was both it was
like a it was like nobody's fault but
like yeah it Terri she went back a
little bit I overestimated it was a it
was a kind of heavy foam SL plastic
typewriter and I hit her and we we
continued playing through the take and
when when Zelda yelled cut I mean I was
on my knees like I'm so sorry but she
was such a champ about it she laughed
again she was a champ about it because
she's such a per she's such a real
artist who's committed to the craft and
she wrote a note to me after she saw the
Final Cut of the movie and it just it
echoes that sentiment of like she she
brought something that we really needed
yeah absolutely and she was the last
person cast in the film yeah I feel like
if she is the last person cast in every
film all those films are better off I
want more than for Carla always so this
is a fun question being heard is a
powerful thing the creature is like her
therapist her boyfriend oh yeah if you
two could pick a movie character to act
as your therapist who would you pick and
why that's fun my instinct was
Scooby-Doo I knew you were going to pick
a dog a dog cuz the first one I thought
about was Doug from up why do I go there
says a lot about me I have a dog named
Buddy very Scooby-Doo like he's a little
silly yeah a movie character uh yeah I'm
going to go with Godzilla different kind
of pet but still I I cuz I feel like my
therapist being like yeah just go thrash
around town would be so nice have you
ever thought of destroying everything
around you I'd be like are you cut out
for this I don't really know I think you
two AC that
question your hand I can't believe
you're here do you like music I have the
Cure oh not that kind of cure they can't
make you better I mean they can but like
emotionally nice complicated two-parter
to start here because I love how this
movie channels like like dark comedies
and and romantic fantasies from the 80s
and early 90s Heather's Edward Scissor
Hands I could go on and on can you each
pinpoint something from those past
movies that you knew you wanted to hold
tight to and include here but then I
also want to know something that you
know maybe those movies didn't explore
enough that you wanted to go really hard
into with Lisa Frankenstein well I kind
of love the slapstick comedy of like
Beetlejuice and I think that some of the
physical comedy from that movie I think
you can definitely see Echoes of it in
in Zelda's direction for sure and then
um I also love the like Lydia Deets goth
Outcast type character which we have
actually seen in quite a few movies in
the ' 80s and I you know I hard relate
and then in terms of what did we do that
was different one thing I love about
being alive today is we get to have
these like real conversations about
mental illness and grief and like be
more vulnerable in our in our dialogue
in a way because when I was growing up I
don't think that people were talking
about that stuff as much so true I'll
lean towards Death Becomes Her because I
really did love that kind of there was a
wackiness in the friendship and also the
violence in that movie but in terms of
what I would hope not that we did better
because I genuinely don't think that you
know that's such a subjective thing but
I I love that we got to explore further
female friendship in this in terms of
especially Taffy and Lisa and their kind
of camaraderie um in the midst of all
that comic violence I appreciated the
complexity in that relationship too I
found that to be like a lot Fuller than
I ever anticipated it was going to be at
the beginning of the movie it wasn't
just at odds like they also there was a
lot of love there that was Death Becomes
Her they went really at odds and then
like even in the end they're still like
beating each other whereas in this
there's like a lot of love underneath
that so this is a little random but this
is the question I was most excited to
ask you both it puts you on the spot
creatively a little bit let's say the
creature from your movie met Emma
Stone's Bella Baxter from poor things oh
man what would they talk about and do
together oh I would rather that he met
Christopher Abbott's character from the
end of the movie and they just kind of
navigated their strength oh that's
interesting though I think uh Bella bter
might have taken things to the next
level physically sooner than Lisa did
that's fair I believe that yeah I mean I
also think they'd be a good dance
partner for each other I there's got to
be a lot of physicality that would be
lovely in that that dance scene was so
wonderful I would love to see that mash
up now that's all I'm going to be
thinking about um Diablo a Jennifer's
Body question for you because I was
reading another interview you did where
you said you thought it was funny that
it was being so heavily included as a
marketing tool here which I for one
loved and it was just making me curious
what do you think it is about how
audiences have evolved that are making
them finally Embrace that movie the way
it should be I mean part of it is like
and I certainly couldn't have predicted
this and didn't plan it but there's
something about like the aesthetic of
that movie that really appeals to jenzie
and I love it and I I it's a bit of a
mystery but it's also very exciting of
course and I also think there are things
that we were doing in that movie like
the queer subtext the dialogue about
misogyny like I think that it was um
maybe just people weren't the mainstream
audiences maybe weren't ready for it at
the time whereas now it's like
conversations people are willing to have
so I'm delighted that like I like I said
I
never thought that that movie would be
used as like an example of what this
movie is like to sell it and I'm like
that's amazing I love it that one of my
first press screenings ever working in
this industry and I vividly remember it
and remember walking out loving it and
then being like why don't doesn't
everybody feel like I do thank you thank
you for being an OG because there
weren't many since day one okay I have a
habit of getting obsessed with uh movie
lore and Bible so did the two of you
create one for the creature and if so I
don't know can you give me maybe like
three rules that were most important to
abide by in terms of how the creature
can operate oh abiding by I was going to
say because we uh the the animated
sequence in the front of the movie
wasn't originally in there but I wanted
to show creatures life because otherwise
the movie never would have discussed it
so we did discuss that like was he a
musician as it turns out and like then
the girl he fell in love with and that
stuff but rules to abide by I for how he
could function and
evolve um we know he can drink milk
that's true which is when I saw that I
was like oh that's interesting he's
drinking a glass of milk he's not
lactose intolerant he's not lactose
intolerant he he can be he can have body
part dead body parts can be reanimated
but only by Taffy's tanning bed and then
I guess the third rule is
um he's just he's just kind of a
sweetheart I third R he does oat milk so
technically he could be a lactosa maybe
it well either way he can he can digest
beverages which yeah okay I mean I would
say he shouldn't probably go walking too
much out in rainstorms either because
truthfully if that thing can resurrect
you I'm sure it can put you back but um
yeah I mean he was so human from the
get-go that was what I really wanted to
portray so I never really wanted to give
him the rules of zombom he's not
contagious he's not giving it to other
people he's a resurrected man no crying
that was like I felt I felt like I I
could smell him just sitting in the
theater smelly tears so Zelda a quote
that I saw you post on your Instagram
that caught my eye you said I doubt I'll
get the chance to make anything this
wonderfully wacky ever again so forgive
me if I ran with it what is something
wonderfully wacky that you wanted to do
you thought someone was going to say no
but they trusted you believed in your
vision and now it's in the final film oh
the penis scene for sure I thought at
some point someone was going to pull the
rug out from underneath like even just
the th because it's on the page that was
in there but also the way I wanted to
shoot it and with the slow motion and
stuff I was like they're going to say no
and then they just they kept not so I
was like I'm just going to keep
functioning as if no one's going to say
no and thankfully now it's still in
there yeah GL fingers crossed we still
have to release but oh it'll be in there
I feel like we're good at this point I
feel like we're safe with that um so now
to follow up on that for both of you
because I want to see more movies like
this I want you to make your case right
now why do we need more wonderfully
wacky movies in this world especially
ones with uh leads that are just so
unapologetically like unique and
themselves I I mean if if it's a simple
answer but if we need them because there
isn't a glut of them you know there's a
lot of uh I'm not going to pick on any
particular genre but I feel like there's
a lot of the same type of movies that
are coming out probably because they're
a guaranteed box office draw and um this
one is different I don't know if there's
anything you could compare this movie to
in the last year you know and so it's
just a story that deserves to be told
it's just the the weirdos need
representation as well we need go
representation like yeah see for me I've
always seen comedy as a really wonderful
kind of I mean hunting ground's not the
best word for it but like a place of
Discovery for really great talent and
it's been a while since they've allowed
as many young people to come in with it
recently you're seeing more of it like I
love what Rachel Senate's been bringing
in and some of the new young girls that
she's brought up with like bodies bodies
bodies and and then with bottoms as well
of like all this kind of Comedy coming
up around the same thing but I'd like to
see even more of that I'd like young
people to have the opportunity what we
got to do here because otherwise how do
you find someone that reminds you of Gan
Wilder or melin Khan how do you bring in
that new energy um they have to expand
it can't just all be dead serious or
it'll all be very dead serious
actors